les policiers arrêtent les magistrats
condamnent c'est après que ça ne va pas
c'est là où je ne vais pas être d'accord
avec monsieur dupont moretti
c'est l'exécution de la peine qui
pêchent dans notre pays ce qui est
important une sanction c'est pas sa
sévérité sa certitude
et force est de constater qu'aujourd'hui
il n'y a plus de certitude de la
sanction ce qui est je crois le problème
numéro un de la justice entre les
décisions de magistrats qui sont
rappelons le des juges indépendants en
france à dépendant du pouvoir politique
ne sont pas appliquées donne deux
exemples
premier exemple vous condamner un
tribunal condamne quelqu'un à un an
jusqu'à un an de prison ferme
eh bien on sait qu'il n'ira pas en
prison ça a quel sens de condamner
quelqu'un à huit mois de prison ferme
parce que donner un coup de poing aux
policiers
tout en sachant qu'il n'ira pas en
prison et de l'autre côté mais on fait
tout pour faire sortir plus tôt les gens
de prison il ya des remises de peine des
remises de peine automatiques ou pas il
ya tout un tas de choses qui fait que
on essaye de les faire sortir pourquoi
parce qu'il n'ya pas assez de places en
prison vous avez 60 mille places en
prison en france
ce n'est pas inintéressant de savoir qu
en angleterre il ya 96 milles en espagne
la 77 milles ça faisait d'ailleurs
partie du des promesses de campagne du
président de république actuel de fer
15000 places de prison ce qu'il faut
faire dans notre démocratie est pour
l'instant zéro a été fait en plus il
n'ya pas une passe de pression de plus
qu'il ya trois ans nous affichent leur
assemblée nationale vis des problèmes
des gens et ne souhaite pas du tout les
résoudre donc l'insécurité arrange le
rassemblement national parce que les
gens vont se tourner de manière
d'ailleurs me semble-t-il maladroite
vers leur assemblée nationale moi je
suis stupéfait de voir qu'au parlement
européen le lancement national de vote
rien n'ont pas voté l'augmentation du
budget de frontex qui permettait
d'employés dix mille gardes frontière de
plus alors vraiment s'il ya un truc est
emblématique dans le programme du front
national c'est la lutte contre
l'immigration
donc c'est ce qu'ils disent mais par
contre bon ils sont à bruxelles et
votent contre l'augmentation du budget
de frontex